the disconnect on the past but the
tremendous bounce take any rest
grab some cell phone look like of the
time Harvin Bagley has the bag he jumps
up and says give me that shot takes it
and gets out on his horse drop it into
the post
nice little left hand jump hook in the
paint look at this grant my knees even
20 in one and here's Luca with it up up
one more time let me give it to you like
Kevin McHale used to give it to us
staying high and right here watch Allen
ready to help but he's got his hands
high coming out to contest a deep three
how about to handle how about the spin
Vince gets him a little bit of
separation the close by kleva my
goodness I'll tell you that's
reminiscent of a handle like Steph Curry
but his favorite here nice drop off and
he just takes Raymond Ray that Jordan
he's attacking his feet and that's what
you've got to do you don't want to play
a late the strength game killer bees
beautiful pass from Harrison finds a
cutting Marvin Bagley
took the hit kept the focus on the grip
so it's gonna be fun curly D let's get
it out look at that it's a good boy
you faked me out no player likes to look
where the ball is here in Memphis grin
so impressive jaren Jackson with the
finish Wow
and water check it out
you gotta make them go to the basket
again a little bit too much room we saw
it developing we knew it was coming
we're gonna get here
you gotta close out eight nothing got
away with a while then Bagley against
Spaulding little quick Japan goes up and
under and close it for the second court
out the way they did they're going to be
a control eight for 14 from the
three-point line
Lucca adding to that from the
three-point line and hanging out with
the soldier named thinker stopping by
the euro
deandre camp nice spin move back to his
right hand just cancer a little bit too
late I almost enough to show three times
yes sir Starr kind of stuff which is
quick spin it's by herder and then how
about a little major slam ajaan the
other side that's the hard part how eyes
getting away from the dead man push off
and step out of bounds as we get another
look at the couple of blocks on LeBron
James
Lilly getting the tip
and watch Brown on this place or where's
oh no wait
I don't know he hadn't run anyway yet
he's at the rim Derrick Dedmon throwing
one down
[Music]
when he turned the corner on Jerebko and
jericho looked like he was expecting
help there's none there that's more
beautiful and then gets rewarded need to
call those out a little better
box elevates missed it the offensive
won't get in position here just under
maybe even got by the little push-off
but they did get by with
since the feet left his hands before the
clock struck double zero
that play as well again not lauded for
his defense does have two steals tonight
cappella ahead of the field block by
Jaron great was covered the best Appel
with model Jaron a trailing three don't
beer front so he goes to LA but he is so
athletic and he ends up Duncan this with
contact go bears gonna pick up a foul
right on the yeah well that's a certain
foul right across the head was a nice
finish by eight like it at the great
finish that time by yeah Luka he
practices that stuff all but watch his
little backdoor good help my watch open
then see Plumlee just closes out on the
right he gates the left and now as a
team who think ok this cool struggling
we okay no no take advantage again no
help by Joelle and be
[Applause]
[Music]
what a play by Trey young the Florida
that he has perfected and getting all
the love on the sideline no man he's
putting together a heck of a game
there's a tenth of a second
smart toppling off as he contested that
was clearly a foul
dodge it Buckman should have gotten the
three hand one
[Music]
stay tuned asked from which angle he
says straight up the middle
blue timeout Sacramento no 5 and this
time to sign of beat the clock and he
does with the Swiss Youngs crazy 3
Austin Rivers all over him Trey young
spread in the lake this is all Luca here
just attack him in the open court
showing off that tremendous skill move
one more time from Trey young you see
the trap right there and he kind of
faked them out with two dribbles now had
the mismatch you thought I was gonna
land up no I'm flashing it on you and
George to the free-throw line as you
look at June just levels off step back
with his third assist of this third
quarter in there Darren's accent great
job great and just weaves his way
through all those white shirts but
double teaming guys that aren't
accustomed to it leads to these type of
situations for the Grizzlies Grizzlies
[Music]